[Music]
so yeah I think there's a few things
that need to happen for crypto
currencies to become kind of a global
replacement for either reserve
currencies global money transfer visa
vie like Swift wires via your bank first
of all the system needs to be massively
liquid right I mean if you think about
dollar as a reserve currency there's
trillions of dollars in circulation it's
globally liquid across tens of thousands
of banks across 185 countries etc etc
that's not totally true of crypto
currencies yet if you take Bitcoin which
is the most successful crypto currency
its market cap is around two hundred
billion dollars as of today it's
tradable in a hundred plus countries but
the liquidity of Bitcoin versus even the
US dollar is relatively low which means
it needs to be worth a lot more if it
would become like let's say a digital
gold gold is worth trillions of dollars
in the aggregate right the coin is not
yet worth that much and that's important
because if if it's not worth trillions
of dollars and billions of people want
to use it there's not enough to go
around so you need to be able to break
it up into tiny pieces so everyone can
use it just like gold and and that's not
true until it's worth a lot more money
than it is today but it becomes a
circular discussion because the usage
will also drive the price higher right
just like speculation sometimes can can
drive the price higher so over time it
should get there by its ability to be
fungible with fiat via these exchanges
as kind of an on-ramp into digital
currency but also it should you know it
should meet the liquidity requirements
that we need meaning the price should be
high enough the ability to get in and
out via traditional money should be
reasonable globally over the next few
years and then I believe you can really
have a viable discussion about using a
crypto currency like Bitcoin as a viable
reserve currency so crypto currencies
eventually will look like traditional
commodities in my opinion whether it's
gold or platinum or other
you know metals or is probably the best
but could look like oil and gas things
like that and and so they they are
starting to trade in in a fashion that's
more and more similar to traditional
commodities but the difference right now
is they're not as liquid yet right so so
that means that the price is is very
inefficient for the markets for crypto
currencies are very inefficient so most
people who are holding crypto currencies
are long-term holders they're not
selling okay so that actually means that
the price of Bitcoin and ether for
example is largely driven by the volume
of buyers so if there's large volumes of
buyers coming into the market it drives
the price higher because there's not a
lot of sellers but if the the buyers dry
up right then the price goes down
regardless because there's still not a
lot of sellers so so that'll change over
time because if the price skyrocket so
for example if institutional money
starts to come into the cryptocurrency
market in large numbers which I think it
will that will force the price higher
because there's not enough
cryptocurrency to go around okay and
that'll also cause some of the holders
to loosen up their purse strings because
they're gonna want to reap the profits
that they've been waiting for for 10-15
years by the time that happens okay and
that'll also create more liquid in the
system which will create a really
positive feedback loop which should
drive the price even higher the other
thing that I think is very relevant is
you're starting to see more traditional
types of financial products being
applied to crypto currencies derivatives
options non-deliverable forward
contracts you know things like that that
actually will help make the
cryptocurrency market more efficient
over time close a lot of what we call
arbitrage loopholes which is kind of
like free money in the system for
traders and as those loopholes get
closed the market becomes more efficient
more liquid and it becomes better for
everyone this I think is a common
misunderstanding with how Bitcoin works
Bitcoin itself is what we call
deflationary which means that over time
the amount of Bitcoin in circulation if
you look at a chart would actually
approach a fixed value of 21 million
never quite approach it
we'll ask methodically in math terms
approach that line of 21 million over
time and it does that by the amount of
Bitcoin being mined or created being cut
in half every so often right right now
it's every few years and then it'll be
every few months and then etc etc right
and so that these happenings actually
create a predictable rate at which
Bitcoin is created that rate like I said
will asymptotically approach 21 million
over several years and at that point
though if Bitcoin is being used for
money transfer applications there's
institutional investors buying it like
digital gold that will drive the price
higher but if the price shoots up to
let's say a trillion dollars right
there's only 21 million it's still not a
problem because you can subdivide
Bitcoin down to eight decimal places so
you can get to the point where one
Satoshi which is point zero zero zero
zero zero zero one Bitcoin could be
worth a thousand dollars right as
opposed to today when Bitcoin is worth
$5,000 eight thousand dollars whatever
it is at today's price right so so the
ability to subdivide Bitcoin into tiny
amounts called Satoshi's which are you
know in today's value fractions of a
penny could eventually be worth
thousands of dollars in their own right
right so that's that gives the utility
of Bitcoin a lot of leg room for the
long term because even if the value goes
up to trillions you'll be able to
subdivide it into small amounts to make
it useful for small payments
[Music]